hey this is prashta walker
arya bhatt mentions he has a twin
brother bhaskar
if one in ten sets of twins are
identical and nine and ten sets of twins
are fraternal
what is the probability that arya but
and bhaskar are identical twins
to be precise identical twins develop
from a single fertilized egg and have
the same sex
fraternal twins develop from two
separate fertilized eggs
suppose the sex of each fraternal twin
is independently determined and equally
likely to be male or female and suppose
that identical twins are equally likely
to be male or female
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
a common mistake is that many people
think the answer is one over ten
if you hear arya but has a twin there is
a one in 10 chance the twin is identical
but if you learn the gender of the twin
that influences the probability
to see why suppose that arya butt
mentions he has a twin sister
as identical twins have the same sex you
could conclude with certainty they are
not identical twins
just as learning arya but has a twin
sister decreases the one in ten chance
he has an identical twin brother
down to zero
learning he has a twin brother
increases the one in ten chance he has
an identical twin brother
there is a precise way to update the
probability based on the probability of
the other events i will explain three
methods which are all flavors of the
same idea
bayes theorem
in the first method we'll compare the
frequencies
consider population with one thousand
sets of twins
out of those thousand sets of twins we
expect one hundred to be identical twins
because that's one in
ten of these we expect equal frequencies
of two gender pairings male male and
female female
so we expect 50 sets of identical twin
brothers
on the other hand we expect 900 to be
fraternal twins because that's nine out
of ten
of these we expect equal frequencies of
four gender pairings male male male
female female male and female female so
we expect 225 sets of fraternal twin
brothers
so in total we expect 50 plus 225 which
equals 275 sets of twin brothers
out of these
50 are identical which is 2 out of 11 or
approximately 18.2 percent
therefore there is a 2 over 11 or
approximately 18.2 percent chance that
arya but who has a twin brother has an
identical twin brother
another way we could solve this problem
is to write a probability tree
twins can either be identical or
fraternal
identical twins can either be female
female or male male with equal
probability and fraternal twins can be
any of the four gender pairings with
equal chance
we're only concerned with twin brothers
so we only want to focus on these two
branches
the probability can be found by
multiplying the probabilities of each
branch
so the probability of identical twin
male brothers is one out of ten times
one half which equals one out of twenty
fraternal twin brothers will be nine out
of ten times one over four which is 9
over 40.
so the total probability of male twin
brothers is equal to the sum of these
which is 1 over 20 plus 9 over 40 which
is equal to 11 over 40.
the probability of identical twin
brothers knowing that they are male twin
brothers
will be the ratio of the top branch to
the entire probability and this works
out to be two over eleven
therefore we get to the same answer of
approximately 18.2 percent
the third way is to work through the
textbook bayes theorem
we'll let i denote the event of
identical twins f denote the event of
fraternal twins and b denote the event
of twin brothers
we're interested in the probability of i
given b
and by bayes theorem this equals the
probability of b given i times the
probability by
all over the probability of b
we can expand out the denominator
because twins are either identical or
fraternal
we now substitute in the relevant
probabilities in each of these
we then simplify to get to the answer of
2 over 11. so again we get to the
approximately 18.2 percent chance
did you figure it out and which method
did you use
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description